s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
non
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
la stratégie politique depuis pas mal
d'années encourage la fracture sociétale
pour éviter d'aborder les questions de
fond pour remettre en cause la pensée
des groupes de pression voire l'étude
démontre la nocivité de l'hydroxyde
rhône au nom de la peur de la mort notre
ministre a interdit immédiatement son
utilisation
le problème c'est que l'étude avait été
faite par des cardiologues sur la base
de données fournies par une société sacs
tissent dont certains des employés ont
des qualifications étonnant allant de
l'auteur de science-fiction à l'hôtesse
mannequin dans cette dictature de la
pensée unique des technocrates les
activistes et de nombreux journalistes
ne s'intéressent qu'à la partie qui va
dans leur sens et censure ou dévalorise
le reste fonds décide de ce que le
peuple doit penser
[Musique]
elle a une ce chiffre plus qu'inquiétant
plus de 7000 cas de covin 19 ces
dernières 24 heures le ministère de la
santé a annoncé ce soir une progression
que les autorités qualifient d'
exponentielle dans ce contexte le port
du masque obligatoire septembre dans
l'hexagone pour faire face à un regain à
des contaminations marseille paris avec
sertic couronne strasbourg et le centre
ville de bordeaux également pour tous à
57 ans après le célèbre discours de
martin luther king la lutte antiraciste
plus que jamais d'actualité aux etats
unis c'est washington
la classe matters a choisi pour y
organiser une grande marche pacifique
objectif défendre les droits des afro
américains après les affaires georges de
floyd et jack black
l'union européenne menaçant car ado
sanctions s'il n'y a pas de progrès dans
le dialogue avec athènes la question
sera même abordé lors de son trou
le 24 septembre la turquie et la grèce 6
disputent des zones riches en
hydrocarbures la crise s'est durcie elf
derniers jours
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
on débute ce journal avec ces derniers
chiffres du colis de 19 plus de 7000 cas
en 24 heures une progression qualifiée
d' exponentielle selon les autorités le
port du masque obligatoire il se
généralise dans l'hexagone si vous
habitez du côté de marseille de paris
avec sa petite couronne ou encore à
strasbourg impossible d'échapper à la
mesure qui risque de s'étendre encore
sur le territoire a bordeaux par exemple
le port d'une protection visage est
obligatoire dans la majeure partie du
centre ville dont les quais de garonne
avec une extension possible du périmètre
si la situation sanitaire en pire c'est
ce qu'indique la mairie pour faire face
donc à ce rebond des contaminations aux
colis de 19 ont fait le point avec
nadège abderrazak si vous circulez ch à
paris dans les départements de seine
saint denis ou du val-de-marne ne vous
êtes comme moi obligé de porter un
masque un masque qui était au mois
d'avril
inutile et pas nécessaire et bien
aujourd'hui il fait figure d'armes
numéro un pour le gouvernement pour
lutter contre la propagation du kobus 19
à compter du vendredi 28 août à 8 heures
le port du masque sera obligatoire pour
tous les piétons circulant dans les
espaces publics les utilisateurs de
vélos deux roues trottinette et autres
engins de mobilité personnelle motorisés
ou non
les usagers circulant à l'intérieur des
véhicules à moteur voitures des
particuliers camionnettes ou poids
lourds des professionnels seront
dispensés de cette obligation
sous la pression de la mairie de paris
notamment la préfecture de police fait
marche arrière ce matin concernant les
cyclistes et les joggeurs finalement ils
ne seront pas concernées par
l'obligation du port du masque mais des
questions restent en suspens porter le
masque partout en extérieur est d'accord
mais at on le droit de le retirer pour
manger pour fumer ou est-ce que c'est
aussi interdite dans les rues de paris
les avis sont mitigés entre ceux qui
n'étaient pas au courant de l'obligation
du port du masque dès ce vendredi 8
heures et ceux qui trouvent là mesures
trop contraignantes
je pense pas que ce soit obligatoire
tout le temps en dents de scie que le
manger
l'enlever trois secondes pour manger
mais il faut le remettre moi tant que je
pense que tant que la personne et pense
à remettre les masques d'encore à la
fini de faire ce qu'elle a à faire
normalement ça devrait être bon je porte
le masque quand il ya une presse dans la
rue effectivement j'ai module en
fonction de l'affluence
je sais bien que c'est obligatoire mais
on a un petit peu de libre arbitre
encore je crois dans ce pays non
espérait honnêtement j'avais pas vu
passer l'info pour aujourd'hui je
pensais que c'était encore avec des saas
reste un et dans des lieux obligatoire
est bon j'ai zappé mais je le porte à
savoir qu'on me dit qu'il faut le porter
voilà c'est un manque d'information mais
recule pas voilà alors ces matériaux
prendre des masques
juste vous en sortir mais on va prendre
des masques ouais on va faire sans
sylvain petit paumé au risque c'est par
là ça va il fait froid aujourd'hui mais
ça va mais quand il fait très très chaud
moi je serai avec le masque on peut pas
respirer quoi c'est fini pour nous c'est
un peu entre guillemets injuste aussi
d'avoir une amende parce qu'on a on
vient de retirer deux minutes le masque
pour parce qu'on avait besoin de
respirer
je sais que j'ai bien un reportage pas
où il y avait une dame sous les infos
qui est à retirer une minute à ces prix
sont 135 euros d'amendé
c'est un peu compliqué donc il ya des
gens qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens
avec cette crise aussi ça c'est un peu
dur c'est une question de logique
j'ai déduit que quand on est assis qu'on
consomme on peut enlever parce qu'on
peut pas confirmer avec le masque quand
on arrête de manger où il faut le
remettre et c'est pour fumer
personnellement je suis pas fumeur dont
je pense qu'on peut s'en passer mais
j'avoue que c'est un peu compliqué je
sais pas trop comment positionner dessus
tant que ça mériterait plus de
précisions et d'ici à ce que la
préfecture de police de paris clarifie
sa position elle sachez que le non port
du masque est puni d'une amende de 135
euros amende qui peut monter jusqu'à
3750 euros en cas de récidive et sur le
port du masque obligatoire je propose
d'écouter j'ai remarqué le président de
l'union française pour une médecine
libre faut être très clair pourquoi on
porte le masque on porte le masque pour
protéger les autres qui ont au teich
quand on est seul dans la rue et qu'on
porte le masque personnes ont peut-être
personne en ironie seuls les seuls
moments où il faut porter le masque les
seuls moments et il est seul basé sur
des véritablement sur des faits
scientifiques ce sont les lieux clos où
il ya des croisés de populations parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya là un vrai risque à
ce moment-là de contamination de masse
et puis les moments où on se trouve en
concentration populationnelle les uns
contre les autres ou on peut transmettre
le virus soit en touchant quelques
soient les postulants dessus tout le
reste ce sont des peurs ou des
protections politiques plus que d'effets
sanitaires
je crois qu'il faut que l'on garde la
tête froide par rapport à cette
infection du virus qui va nous
accompagner malheureusement pendant des
mois et des mois qui va impacter nos
vies pendant des mois et des mois et
parce que nous allons devoir organiser
nos vies par rapport à ce virus il faut
que l'organisation les choses de façon à
ce que l'on ait des plages de liberté
des lieux où l'on retrouve un peu le
vide avant de façon à ce qu'on puisse un
peu en quelque sorte respirer
le ministre chinois des affaires
étrangères ont mis en france il effectue
une tournée européenne huit mois après
le début de l'épidémie de koral un virus
partie de chine le président emmanuel
macron lui accorde aujourd'hui une
audience à l'elysée au programme
notamment la 5g de huawei la situation
au congo ou encore les relations
commerciales on voit tout cela en images
non
on
[Musique]
non non
n'ayons pas une espèce de naïveté qui
consiste à dire que c'est beaucoup plus
fort on ne sait pas et même il ya
manifestement des choses qui se sont
passées et qu'on ne sait pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde
[Musique]
nous envisageons des mesures que je
serai amené à diffuser le moment venu il
ya vraiment une rupture par rapport à la
loi fondamentale de 1997 par rapport au
principe un pays deux systèmes donc on
ne va pas rester comme cela
[Musique]
justement à propos de la 5g de wawel
écoutez l'analyse de pierre picard
géopolitologue spécialiste de la chine
pour ce qui me concerne je dirais qu'il
s'agit plutôt de faire plaisir à nos
alliés traditionnels américains je pense
qu'elle est les chinois ont dit
plusieurs fois vu qu'ils étaient
partenaires avec de nombreuses sociétés
publiques ou privées occidentales et
qu'ils étaient prêts à accepter tout ça
tout le protocole de contre les autres
donc je ne suis pas un expert en
télécommunications et en iran numérique
mais je pense que on est plus prêt à
faire un effort pour faire plaisir je
dirais à la bonté géopolitique que la
mairie qui se heurtent rythmant la chine
mais un moment d'autres pays aux etats
unis toujours à cette colère anti
raciste elle a gagné aujourd'hui la
capitale washington une manifestation
intitulée enlever votre genou de nos
coûts en référence à la mort de joe de
floyd est organisée ce jour date
anniversaire de l'emblématique discours
de martin luther king
outre la ferrade genre de flop plus
récemment celle de jacob black
akhannouch a dans le whisky s'il tout
cela rappelle la défense des droits à
des afro américains qui reste toujours à
un coup bas aujourd'hui si on fait le
point avec grégoire douce et c'est une
manifestation massive qui est attendu à
washington ce vendredi un fort regain de
mobilisation sur fond de tensions
extrêmes faisant suite à la diffusion
d'une vidéo montrant un homme noir
blessé grièvement lors de son
interpellation
jacob blake un père de famille de 29 ans
a été touché de sept balles dans le dos
tiré à bout portant par un policier
blanc
s'ajoutent à cela les meurtres présumés
de deux manifestants anti brutalité
policière par un adolescent de 17 ans
militants armés prenant l'autodéfense
pour de nombreux citoyens américains
ces tragédies fonds submergé un vase qui
déborde depuis déjà trop longtemps
si nous luttions contre le racisme
comme nous luttons contre le terrorisme
les individus racistes avec des
rhétorique raciste serait bien plus
réticents et aurait bien plus de
difficultés à être dehors à la vue de
tous
comme ce tireur de 17 ans l'a été si
jacob blake avait été un homme noir de
17 ans avec une arme chargée il ne
serait pas envie aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire du high rise dream de
martin luther king arrive donc à point
nommé pour les manifestants une large
fenêtre d'exposition pour servir la
lutte contre le racisme et les violences
qui en découlent
à un peu plus de deux mois de l'élection
présidentielle la question des violences
policières s'avère d'ores et déjà être
un des enjeux cruciaux de la campagne
américaine est aujourd'hui encore un
porte-parole de l'onu a rappelé la
nécessité d'éliminer le racisme au sein
de la police
après laffaire à jacob black a blessé
grièvement par les forces de l'ordre
dans ce contexte autant du en pleine
pandémie également donald trump a
clôturé hier la hier soir la convention
républicaine une sortie a perturbé par
plusieurs centaines de manifestants du
mouvement black live matters rassemblées
devant la maison blanche dans la halle
trump a officiellement accepté la
nomination du parti républicain pour
briguer un second mandat et il s'en est
pris à son rival démocrate joe biden
nous avons passé les quatre dernières
années à réparer les dommages causés par
joe biden ses 47 dernières années la
carrière de baden et honteusement rempli
des trahisons et des gaffes les prix
catastrophique de notre temps joe biden
n'est pas le sauveur de l'âme de la
mairie qu'il est le destructeur des
emplois de l'amérique
si on lui en offre l'occasion il sera le
fossoyeur de la grandeur de l'amérique
cette élection décidera si nous sauvons
le rêve américain ou si nous permettons
un programme socialiste de démolir notre
chère des secours
dans l'actualité l'union européenne
agite l'épouvantail des sanctions contre
la turquie il faut de dialogue avec la
grèce on le rappelle les deux parties se
disputent une zone riche en
hydrocarbures en méditerranée orientale
s il n'ya pas d'apaisement bruxelles
pourrait décider de sanctions lors de
son prochain sommet le 24 septembre à la
crise gréco-turque faisait l'objet hier
et aujourd'hui d'une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères à des
états membres à berlin cette crise elle
semble s'aggraver surtout depuis hier
avec l'annoncé d'un accord entre la
grèce et l'egypte sur le partage est des
zones maritimes d'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures
on revient justement sur ces tensions
avec hélas ma tête
l'egypte et la grèce sont désormais
autorisés à tirer chacune le maximum
davantage les ressources disponibles
dans la zone économique exclusive
notamment des réserves de pétrole et de
gaz un traité signé en réponse à
l'accord conclu entre la turquie et la
libye fin 2019
cette entente turco-libyenne autorisant
car à accéder à une large zone en
méditerranée orientale où d'importants
gisements d'hydrocarbures ont été
découverts ces dernières années il faut
dire que l'enjeu est de taille pour la
grèce et la turquie en méditerranée
orientale le bassin levantin qui s'étend
de la crète et de l'île de rodez à
l'ouest jusqu'aux côtes asiatiques à
l'est recèle 5765 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz estimations de la
commission géologique américaine
réalisée en 2010 ankara mène depuis
plusieurs mois des recherches en
hydrocarbures dans cette zone disputée
le 10 août dernier le déploiement d'un
navire de recherches sismiques turc et
de son escorte militaire au sud de l'île
grecque de kastellorizo a été vécu par
la grèce comme la provocation de trop et
à déclencher une escalade des tensions
après plusieurs semaines de bras de fer
en mer méditerranée orientale athènes et
ankara ont multiplié les manoeuvres
militaires ces derniers jours la turquie
a fait savoir ce jeudi qu'elle
procéderait à des exercices militaires
lui en des exercices de tir les 1er et 2
septembre prochain au large de ses côtes
au nord-est de chypre en face chypre
justement la grèce la france et l'italie
font front commun en méditerranée
orientale dans le cadre d'une initiative
de coopération des navires américains
sont également présents dans le cadre
des missions de l'otan
mais les états unis ne semblent pas
vouloir prendre parti jusqu'à présent la
méditerranée n'avait en tout cas pas
connu une telle présence militaire
depuis de nombreuses années la guerre
ouverte est encore loin mais la montée
des tensions entre athènes et ankara se
poursuit bel et bien et on revient sur
les enjeux de cette crise avec gérard
abbé pierre il est chercheur associé à
la fondation à d'études pour le moyen
orient dans un premier temps là tout le
monde essaye d'avoir le maximum
d'arguments pour aller à la table de
négociation à une tension supérieure
d'ordre de militaires comme vous l'avez
signalé est fort peu probable donc il
s'agit pour tous les partis et la
turquie en particulier a donc d'avoir le
maximum d'éléments dans son jeu il faut
dire que avec l'arrivée des découvertes
de gaz et potentiellement aussi de
pétrole dans la région depuis quelques
années a redistribué les cartes dans la
mesure où avant il n'y avait que des
histoires de pêche donc peu d'intérêt et
d'enjeux économiques
maintenant il y à des milliards de
dollars et quand il ya des milliards de
dollars et surtout autour de l'énergie
eh bien chacun essaye d'avoir la
mainmise ou une part de ce gâteau comme
l'on dit
l'union européenne appelle moscou à
s'abstenir d'intervenir en biélorussie
par la voix de son représentant pour la
diplomatie jose à bord elle à cela fait
suite à l'annoncé du président russe sur
un possible soutien sécuritaire c'est la
situation venait à dégénérer à la
biélorussie toujours secoué par des
manifestations depuis la réélection
contestée d'alexandre loukachenko pour
un sixième mandat
et sachez que les journalistes des
médias russes arrêtés lors d'une
manifestation à minx ja ont été relâchés
certains d'entre eux pourront poursuivre
leur travail en biélorussie c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le porte-parole de
l'ambassade russe dans le pays
[Musique]
toute intervention extérieure en
biélorussie conduirait à
internationaliser cette question et le
pire et l'intervention russe
notre volonté d'engager la russie dans
un dialogue sur la biélorussie et de
nous aider à convaincre le président
lukashenko de la nécessité d'accepter
une médiation de l'eau a eu ce que le
président poutine a pu dire à la
chancelière merkel et à moi même c'est
que lui était favorable à une médiation
au sc eux mais pas le président
loukachenko
donc il a des efforts à faire pour nous
aider en ce sens on en vient à l'as far
alexeï navalni le ministère de la
justice allemand a refusé de confirmer à
l'agencé ria novosti une demande
d'assistance juridique de la russie sur
la situation à dolo opposants russes le
motif la confidentialité de la procédure
alexeï navalni est hospitalisé à berlin
l'établissement affirme que son état
santé montre des signes d'amélioration
et il est toujours plongé dans un coma
artificiel sur l' enquête
sachez que la police russe a annoncé
hier avoir lancé des vérifications
préliminaires et sur le front
diplomatique la chancelière allemande
angela merkel précise qu'il ne faut pas
mêler à la sphère le projet économique
north stream 2 écoutez
[Musique]
je pense que ces deux questions doivent
être examinée séparément
j'estime que ce projet doit être mise en
oeuvre c'est un projet commun entre des
acteurs économiques russes et européens
il y a bien évidemment des aspects
politiques
nous nous sommes donc efforcé de
préserver l'accord sur le transit du gaz
russe via l'ukraine nous resteront
favorables au maintien de ce transit
pour moi il serait inapproprié de lit ce
projet économique à la situation autour
d'alexis navalni s'il ya des sanctions
extraterritoriale imposées par les états
unis
et j'estime que l'incident lié à navalni
ou l'assassinât dans le parc de
tiergarten sont malgré tout des
questions distinctes et de son côté le
kremlin via son porte parole dimitri
peskov a appelé à ne pas tirer de
conclusions hâtives
nous ne pouvons pas tirer de conclusions
hâtives
nous ignorons pour l'instant s'il s'agit
d'un empoisonnement ou non quelque chose
d'autre a pu causer cet état de santé
nous n'en savons rien si des médecins
ont des raisons de croire que cette
hypothèse peut être considérée comme la
version principale
je crois qu'il nous fournirons des
informations supplémentaires
le premier ministre japonais shinzo abe
a démissionné pour des raisons de santé
après sept ans à elie mois la tête du
pays il a battu un record de longévité à
son poste mais une maladie inflammatoire
chronique des intestins la force et à
jeter l'épongé
on écoute je tiens à m'excuser
sincèrement étonné auprès du peuple
japonais de quitter mon poste alors
qu'il ne reste qu'un an à mon mandat en
pleine crise du coronavirus alors que
diverses politiques sont encore en cours
de mise en oeuvre
je vais continuer à remplir faire
maintenant mes fonctions jusqu'à ce
qu'un nouveau premier ministre soit
nommé
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu doit se
prononcer ce soir sur le renouvellement
de la mission de la finul au liban le
pays du cèdre qui risque de voir
disparaître selon la sémantique est
fière de jean yves le drian le chef de
la diplomatie française appelle beyrouth
à la formation rapide d'un gouvernement
et à l'adoption de réformes d'urgence
pour éviter un naufrage et ce après la
double explosion début août dans le port
de la capitale directrice générale de
l'unesco s'est rendu hier sur place pour
constater les dégâts
on y revient en images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les premières estimations dont nous
disposons 159 écoles publiques et privés
ont été endommagés à des degrés divers
parfois même détruite par l'explosion du
4 août
[Musique]
dix jours après le coup d'état militaire
au mali la cedeao tape du poing sur la
table elle exige une transition civile
immédiate en échange d'une levée des
sanctions l'organisation s'est réunie en
visioconférence aujourd'hui tout va
dépendre des avancées selon mahamadou
issoufou le chef de l'état nigérian et
président en exercice de l'institution
ouest africaine est la junte militaire à
libérer le président déchu ibrahim
boubacar keita n'est pour l'instant les
balkans elle prévoit de transférer le
pouvoir aux civils
elle avait été évoquée de transition
militaire de trois ans est la cedeao a
décidé un embargo avec la fermeture des
frontières avec le mali et l'arrêt des
flux commerciaux et financiers par
ailleurs on l'a appris aujourd'hui selon
un document publié sur le site du
journal officiel malien le chef de la
junte ainsi meego rita seraient investis
des prérogatives présidentielles une
information donc à confirmer
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle en côte d'ivoire ont
jusqu'à lundi minuit pour déposer leurs
dossiers alassane ouattara a déjà déposé
le sien le président en exercice brigue
un troisième mandat jugée
anticonstitutionnelle par l'opposition
elle est pro gbagbo ont indiqué qu'ils
déposeraient également le dossier de
l'ex président même initiative pour son
bras droit
charles blé goudé pour l'ancien chef
rebelle guillaume soro
tous les trois ont été radiés des listes
électorales recours ayant été rejetée
aussi quant à l'ancien président
ivoirien henri konan-bédié chef de file
de la principale formation de
l'opposition le parti démocratique de
côte d'ivoire il a déposé sa candidature
hier on va écouter à ce propos l'analyse
des noëls où les présidents de l'union
des femmes du pdci rda le parti d'henri
konan bédié justement nos au pdc nous
nous sommes inscrits au service le
peuple souverain de côte d'ivoire
et quand nous pensons que nous avons
tissé une alliance et que nous nous
sommes trompés sur la nature de
l'alliance une nounou revient de droit
de nous retirer et de chercher de
nouveaux alliés
c'est dans ce cadre là
monsieur blême comme on appelle gbagbo
laurent de nouveaux alliés et nous
défendons sa cause nous demandons à ce
que alassane dramane ouattara essaient
de faire profil bas qui même prendre une
loi d'aministie pousse à retourner les
exilés ou permettent à tous les
antagonistes à tous les leaders de
partis politiques de participer
librement à ces élections c'est qui va
apaiser le climat social qui est
vraiment dvd à qui est très tendue en ce
moment et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver dans 30 minutes selon soir à
vous et restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
et
bon
[Musique]
ceux-là
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire